it's just you
[Music]
Justin and Ariana deliver on their
promise of an isolation anthem their new
duet stuck with you also comes with a
self tapes music video chock-full of
fans and some loved up celebs Demi
Lovato whose manager Scooter Braun also
reps Justin and Ariana plants a kiss on
rumored boyfriend max Eric winneth
Paltrow and hubby Brad Falchuk also pop
up in the video sharing a slow dance in
matching PJ's and there's plenty of PDA
between Justin and wife Haley but ariana
is also seen getting cozy with a new man
who's believed to be La real-estate
agent Dalton Gomez
but there's one social media sensation
who didn't make the cut yo you cool cats
and kittens it's Carolyn big cat rescue
tiger Kings Carrol Baskin and her
husband Howard did submit a clip for the
video which Justin shared as a tease on
Twitter but re revealed she blocked the
controversial animal activist from
appearing in the final edit telling a
fan she had a quote effing heart attack
over the issue the new track also
supports a worthy cause proceeds from
the song streams will benefit the first
responders Children's Fund an
organization that provides grants and
scholarships for children of those
working on the front lines during these
tough times
[Music]